oh this is a fox alert we just reported  it few moments ago that British Prime  Minister Boris Johnson has now been  admitted to the hospital he has symptoms  of carniverous his office 10 Downing  Street says the Prime Minister continues  to have persistent symptoms this 10 days  after he tested positive you know he's  been working in his office kind of  barricaded inside 10 Downing Street  they've been putting his meals outside  his door the office says that the Prime  Minister will undergo tests and he is  urging the public to stay indoors light  light likewise Queen Elizabeth addressed  the nation within the last hour or so  rallying their spirits of the British  people she said that we will succeed  against this virus Her Majesty saying  quote better days will return